nobody yells about cake like that and
libby you know what a cake should make
you
happy you're not making sense today that
dad and andre
have finalized their deal together you
just told us that he's trying to cut his
daughters
dad stop because he currently has you
wrapped around his fingers
so stop are you are you right there
being buddy buddy with him my kids are
gonna hear us
what did you expect we know that you
guys are in cahoots and he is coming
into the family business and trying to
push us
out now we're all fighting together
there's definitely a rift in the family
now there's been a rift in the family
and unfortunately my dad is just so far
up his ass he cannot see it he can't
even hear it
you're calling me to be in cahoots with
my daughter
and my son-in-law that's not cahoots i
just see him taking money out of my
pocket and when it's coming out of my
pocket
i will go in and i'm not gonna stop
until
i get what i want i don't like when
people mess with my money
and he's messing with my finger at us
like you're better than us
i want to hear what they have to say i
already told you what we found how is it
what do you have to say i have to say
the way i helped y'all
in the way i'm helping them is the same
no it's not there
i think my girls are definitely over
racking this deal because this is just
one of the houses that we're flipping
and they think it's going to be the
whole entire company that's not the case
i'm here to help my daughter and my
son-in-law
and that's it
[Music]
you're all getting a share of his found
the property
straight away from the cake into my face
and uh
it's disgusting move and this is the
last straw
jen and rebecca are acting like
teenagers i'm done with it i don't want
to take it anymore
i have a good thing going on with jack
at this moment of time
and i don't want elizabeth siblings
dragging me in a very pity drama thing
we're out of here libby bye
bye we will not stay here and be treated
like that absolutely not
get out of my house